[Musik]
wer hätte das gedacht ziemlich junge
Leute werben für einen ziemlich alten
Kandidaten auch wenn mcken Drake und die
anderen nicht direkt für Joe Biden
Wahlkampf machen der Verein black voters
matter will das möglichst viele
mitmachen bei den Vorwahlen am Samstag
und der Präsidentschaftswahl im
November wir wissen wie wichtig es ist
die Menschen fürs wählen zu begeistern
wenn sie nicht wählen werden die Stimmen
der schwarzen nicht gehört der
Stimmzettel ist deine
Stimme es geht jetzt um Ideen nicht ums
Alter der eine will das Land Spalten der
andere will es
einen nur wenn Sie wählen gehen kann Joe
Biden gewinnen 2020 bekam er bundesweit
über 80% der schwarzen Wähler Stimmen
nach Umfragen jetzt wären es wohl nur
noch
64% dabei bemüht er sich wie hier beim
Besuch im Barbershop in Columbia der
Hauptstadt von South Carolina erzählt
Joe Biden allen was kamamela Harris und
er schon geschafft haben besonders für
die schwarze Minderheit Millionen
Menschen aus der Armut geholfen eine
schwarze als oberste Bundesrichterin
Schuldenerlasse für Studenten so soll es
weitergehen aber sein wichtigstes
Argument ist wie 2020 Donald Trump nur
wenn er besiegt werde könne man dann
[Musik]
sagen
auf dem Spiel und wir haben sie
gerettet seid ihr dabei lst es uns zu
Ende bringen der Wahlkampf wird
furchtbar meint Paul begalla ein Berater
von Präsident Clinton er kennt beidens
Strategie die Tiefe existenzielle Angst
zu nutzen die Demokraten und viele
unabhängige Wähler vor Herrn Trump haben
ist essenziell er ist eine Bedrohung für
eure
Gesundheitsversorgung
Altersvorsorge für euren Job sicher auch
für das Recht der Frauen auf Abtreibung
und für unser ganzes
Regierungssystem er muss sagen dass der
andere viel schlimmer wäre das erfordert
einen sehr sehr negativen Wahlkampf
brutal und hässlich aber das ist beidens
beste Chance könnte das funktionieren
latosa Brown die Gründerin von Black
voters hat zum Diskussionsabend geladen
er beginnt mit der Bitte steht mal auf
wenn ihr Freunde und Familienangehörige
habt die auf keinen Fall Joe Biden
wählen
wollen ein Stoßseufzer der
Moderatorin und
dann mitten im Präsidentschaftswahlkampf
geschieht ein
Völkermord das macht mich ganz
fertig wie können wir trotzdem klar
machen dass es wichtig ist zur Wahl zu
gehen
viele hier halten beiden für zu Israel
freundlich er tue zu wenig für die
Palästinenser befreit euch von dem
irglauben wir könnten einen perfekten
Kandidaten finden in einem Land voller
Unzulänglichkeiten für schwarze waren
Wahlen immer eine pragmatische
Entscheidung mindestens um Schaden zu
verringern denn der größte Schaden so
sagen die Aktivisten drohe durch ihn
auch wenn Donald Trump das bestreitet
wir besuchen den Mann der Trumps
Wahlkampf mit brandreden flankiert in
seiner Talkshow zweimal täglich live
über Social Media
Plattformen Steve bnon exberater von
Trump will dass die reine
nationalpopulistische Bewegung wie er
sie nennt mit Trump als starkem Mann
bald die Macht
übernimmt in der rechten Szene Träumen
manche gar von einer Art Diktator roter
caar genannt rot ist die Farbe der
republikanischen Partei Trump so bennen
werde tausende von
regierungsmitarbeitern durch
Gefolgsleute
ersetzen das machen wir nach dem
überwältigenden Sieg das Volk will das
wir zerstören den administrativen Staat
Stein um Stein unsere Gründungsväter
wollten nicht dass wir in aller Welt in
Bündnissen stecken sie wollten ganz
sicher auch kein Imperium sie wollten
nicht dass irgendwelche Aristokraten das
Sagen haben und ganz besonders wollten
sie keine Machtmonopol
also kein roter Caesar oder Monarch das
ist
lächerlich Diktator wolle er sein hat
Trump selbst gesagt aber nur für den
allerersten Tag im neuen Amt wenn er
übernimmt müssen zwei Dinge sofort
passieren massive Haushaltskürzungen das
wird die armen treffen das verstehe ich
und wir müssen die Grenzen versiegeln
und 8 Millionen illegale eindringlige
deportieren
solche Sätze sind Wasser auf die Mühlen
von beidens Wahlkampf denn sie erzeugen
genau die Angst die er braucht und die
notwendige
Geschlossenheit in Charleston treffen
sich die Aktivisten mit Pfarrern deren
Einfluss auf die Wahlbeteiligung nicht
zu unterschätzen ist viele von ihnen
engagieren sich schon seit Jahrzehnten
in der Bürgerrechtsbewegung und sie
haben hier nicht vergessen wie Trump als
Präsident weiße Rassisten und
gewalttätige Milizen verharmlost
[Musik]
hat zur Wahl stehen die Demokratie und
die Zukunft Amerikas keine Übertreibung
ihr seid aus Deutschland ihr wisst wie
einfach es für die Leute war es
zuzulassen die Menschen vergessen dass
Hitler sich nicht selbst wählte sondern
gewählt wurde wir müssen verhindern dass
ich das in Amerika
wiederholt also so stellt er bei seiner
Predigt an diesem Sonntag seiner
Gemeinde eine
Frage Demokratie oder Diktatur wir
können bei der Antwort
helfen aber beiden muss eine
überwältigende Mehrheit der schwarzen im
Land davon überzeugen dass sie das
Schlimmste nur dann verhindern wenn sie
ihn
wiederwählen